نقلت صحيفه ور ستريت جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان الولايات المتحده تتجه
لارسال الدبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا
الصحيفه الامريكيه اكدت ان الاعلان عن
ارسال الدبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا سيكون
هذا الاسبوع رغم تصريحات الامريكيه سابقه
تحدثت عن مشاكل قط وجهها اوكرانيا
بالتعامل مع الدبابات بالصيانه والتشغيل
الى ذلك اكدت صحيفه ديرشبيل الالمانيه ان
برلين سترسل 10 دبابات لوفات الى اوكرانيا
لكن موعد الوصول غير محدد كما ستسمح للدول
التي تملكها كابولندا بارسالها الى اخرى
نقلت ان الشغل سيعلن ارسال الدبابات
ليوباد الى اوكرانيا غدا امام البرلمان
الالماني وفي اول تعليق لها الرئاسه
الاخرانيه تعتبر ارسال المئات الدبابات
الكاف دفعه للديمقراطيه